[Música]
la cultura está siendo remodelada
continuamente ya que cada generación va
pasando sus historias y sus ideas para
conservar el legado de su identidad un
enfoque popular para este desarrollo
social es el intercambio musical ya que
es una manera entretenida de abrir el
diálogo entre temas sociales económicos
y políticos mientras expone la
aceptación de comunicar emociones y
opiniones
monterrey es una de las ciudades más
importantes para el rock en méxico con
cientos de escenarios festivales
admirados internacionalmente y estudios
de primera gracias a su staff ya su
equipo existen infinitas posibilidades
para que artistas expongan sus
creaciones
el poder teniente local es muy común
pero a veces a social no se da cuenta
del impacto que estos artistas pueden
llegar a tener en diversas comunidades y
como todos sabemos lo hemos escuchado el
mundo del entretenimiento es muy
competitivo pero con las herramientas y
el apoyo y el enfoque correcto su
negocio manejable para prosperar y
progresar exactamente sin con un
movimiento de avanzada regia surgió y
creció adentro de la industria musical
durante la década de los 90 se formaron
múltiples bandas de rock que se hicieron
cargo de la escena musical en nuestro
país
debido a que la capital nueve meses no
estaba preparada para el este éxito
inesperado la comunidad se apresuró para
probar su talento local pero nunca nadie
se imaginó que este talento iba a
resonar en todo el mundo representando
su cultura regia
una de las características más
importantes y distintivas de este
movimiento fueron las fusiones de
corrientes musicales la mezcla de
géneros actuaron como seres personales
para cada de las bandas y el entorno de
cross ya los músicos también ayudó para
crear pasos propuestas diversas que
estaban saliendo en diferentes puntos de
la ciudad por ejemplo pero mi abuelo
salió el gran silencio que mezclaba el
ska el reggae la cumbia y el rock con
letras pegajosas y animadas
de santa catarina salió al cartel de
santa que mezclaba el rap el hip hop y
el rock y hablaba del activismo diario
que vivían en su comunidad
y de san pedro las de garcía salieron
bandas como plastilina mosh rumbo sur
movimiento y control machete
y por más que todas estas bandas tenían
sonidos muy diferentes todos se juntaban
en el epicentro del rock de la ciudad
conocido como el barrio antiguo
aquí bares como el esquís o la tumba y
el café iguana abrió sus puertas para el
talento regiomontano joven
otra característica que ayudó para que
este movimiento saliera a la luz fueron
los medios programas como desveladas
televisión y desvelados radio con cuando
mon palacios y dis villarreal abrieron
una nueva oportunidad para estos músicos
ya que las entrevistas entrevistado
además el músico detrás del instrumento
más que de superestrella y esto es hizo
que mucha gente conectará y pudiera
unirse también al movimiento
la transición de monterrey fue una de
las ciudades representativas del rock
aquí en nuestro país tienen muchas
historias pero todas ellas concuerdan en
que la conclusión de las disqueras del
df escucharon el ruido que estaba
pasando aquí en monterrey y decidieron
venir a ver por ellos mismos y cuando
llegaron a monterrey se dieron cuenta de
incubadora de talento que estaba
sucediendo en el barrio antiguo cuando
llevaron por tanto de sombra que no
sabían cómo escribir todos estos géneros
todas estas corrientes y todas estas
bandas que decidieron castigarlos bajo
una misma identidad
riccardo grado de la revista nuestro
rock del df
un hombre en el movimiento de avanzada
región bajo el género rock región y
aunque muchos de estos artistas regios
no estaban muy de acuerdo con el
nombramiento porque sentía que era una
etiqueta externa que le estaban usando
para publicitar los siete del nombre y
fue así como el movimiento de avanzada
región se hizo muchísimo más famosa
una cultura aspira a hacer crecer a cada
miembro de su comunidad hacer
movimientos que hagan a todos aprender
más de ellos mismos y actuar como grupo
no se trate de sobresalir sino de
representar eso mismo que intentas
cambiar y lo más increíble es que este
movimiento la avanzada regia es aquí de
monterrey de nuestra ciudad y repito los
regios somos aquí y una de las cosas más
interesantes es que ahorita estamos
viviendo lo que este movimiento inspiró
que es la nueva generación porque la
nueva generación de músicos ya está
lista
gracias